aquí tenemos una ecuación que nos dice a
x + 3 x esto es igual a b x + 5 y lo que
quiero que hagamos juntos es resolver
para x y si resolvemos para x ésta va a
quedar en términos de ave y de otros
números entonces pausa el vídeo y ver si
puedes resolver esto por tu cuenta
ok vamos a hacerlo juntos y lo primero
que quiero hacer es agrupar todos los
términos con x del lado izquierdo de la
ecuación y para eso me falta poner este
b x del lado izquierdo de la ecuación
como lo voy a pasar del otro lado bueno
lo que voy a hacer es restar b x de
ambos lados de la ecuación voy a restar
b x de este lado y también voy a restar
b x de este lado y entonces que me va a
quedar bueno me va a quedar lo siguiente
lo voy a poner con este color lo voy a
poner con este color y me va a quedar a
x 3 x de ponerlo así a x + 3 x y después
hay que quitarle b x así que por pura
diversión lo voy a poner con este color
le voy a quitar b x muy bien esto del
lado izquierdo y ahora del lado derecho
que me va a quedar bueno me va a quedar
que estos dos se van a ir déjame ponerlo
así este y este se va y solamente me
quedo con
me quedo simplemente con 5 y ahora ya
que tengo todos los términos que tienen
que ver con x del lado izquierdo de la
ecuación lo que puedo hacer es sacar a x
como factor común entonces podemos
escribir esto de la siguiente manera
podemos escribir esto como x x que
multiplica a quien bueno observa que
primero tengo a x y al dividirlo entre x
voy a obtener simplemente a am más y
después tengo 3x / x me da simplemente 3
y por último tengo menos b x / x lo cual
me da menos ve muy bien y esto claro va
a ser igual a 5 así que déjame pegar un
poco más este paréntesis y vamos a poner
que esto va a ser igual a 5 ahora para
despejar a x lo único que necesito hacer
es dividir todo entre más 3 menos ven
así que vamos a dividir a ambos lados
entre
3 - bm y también este lado lo voy a
dividir entre
3 - bm así que del lado izquierdo este
con este se van y me queda simplemente
que x va a ser igual a quien bueno va a
ser igual a 55 que está dividido por a
más
3 - ven y ya está así obtenemos el valor
de x así que vamos a hacer uno más y
para eso déjame bajar la pantalla para
hacer el siguiente ejercicio este de
aquí y dice am que multiplican a 5 - x
es igual a b x menos 8 y de nuevo quiero
obtener una expresión para x así que una
vez más pausa el vídeo y ver si puedes
resolver para x bueno la forma que a mí
me gusta usar para resolver esto es la
siguiente lo que me gusta es expandir
todo lo que se pueda esta expresión que
tengo aquí y después voy a poner todos
los términos que tienen que ver con x de
un lado de la ecuación y todo lo que no
tiene que ver con x del otro lado de la
ecuación esencialmente voy a hacer justo
en lo que hice en el ejemplo anterior
así que para eso lo primero que se me
ocurre es expandir esta multiplicación
que tengo aquí es decir me voy a tomar
am que multiplican primero a 5 y después
me voy a tomar a a que multiplica a
menos x lo que vamos a hacer es
distribuir esta am y lo primero que me
va a quedar es a por 5 y bueno a por 5
es lo mismo que 5 a 5 am es lo mismo que
a por 5 y después me quedan am que
multiplica a menos x a que multiplica
menos x es lo mismo que menos a amd x
muy bien todo esto es lo que pasa del
lado izquierdo y del lado derecho
solamente me quedan
x menos 8 estás de acuerdo y ya que
tenemos esto que te parece si pasamos
todo lo que tiene que ver con x del lado
izquierda de la ecuación y todo lo que
no tiene que ver con x del lado derecho
de la ecuación así que lo primero que
puedo ver es que necesito quitar estévez
x para pasarlo del lado izquierdo de la
ecuación por lo tanto voy a restar b x
de ambos lados de esta ecuación
esta expresión y si queremos que todo lo
que tiene que ver con x esté del lado
izquierdo y todo lo que no tiene que ver
con x esté del lado derecho entonces
este 5 a me estorba y para quitarlo lo
que voy a hacer es quitar 5 am de ambos
lados de esta expresión voy a quitar 5
am y aquí también voy a quitar 5 y ahora
sí que me va a quedar de todo esto bueno
pues observan que del lado izquierdo
voy a obtener que esté 5 am y este menos
5 a se van y simplemente me queda menos
x que es este de aquí menos b x menos b
x es muy bien y del lado derecho que me
va a quedar este y este se van y me
queda simplemente menos ocho menos cinco
a menos 5
ahora observan en este caso tenemos que
todos son negativos así que antes de
factorizar a x que te parece si le
cambiamos el signo a todo para que sea
mucho más fácil trabajarlo y para
convertir todo positivo lo que voy a
hacer es multiplicar por menos uno a
ambos lados de esta expresión y se
multiplica por menos uno es del lado
izquierdo que voy a obtener bueno voy a
obtener que éste se vuelve positivo y me
va a quedar a x después obtengo que éste
también se vuelve positivo me va a
quedar b x y bueno del lado derecho al
multiplicar por menos uno estos dos
también se van a convertir en positivos
8 más 5 a más 5 de lujo y ya que tenemos
esto que te parece si sacamos como
factor común a x para así ya estar muy
cerca de terminar
voy a sacar como un factor como una
equis y que me va a quedar bueno me
queda x que multiplica a quien
multiplica
a más
y bueno esto a quien va a ser igual va a
ser igual a esta parte que tengo aquí 8
5 a 8 más 5 am y ahora sí que te parece
si dividimos todo si dividimos todo
tanto el lado izquierdo como el lado
derecho entre a más ven para ya estar
muy cerca de terminar a más ven más ven
y también de este lado voy a dividir
todo entre am más b así que éste con
éste se van y ahora sí simplemente voy a
obtener que x va a ser igual a 8 5 am
déjenme ponerlos con sus respectivos
colores 8 + 5 am y esto a su vez está
dividido entre ambas b entre
más ve y ya con esto hemos terminado
resolvimos para x en términos de a y b y
otras cosas pero con esto ya obtenemos
una expresión para x y así podemos decir
que hemos terminado